[Music]
hello everyone my name is Vitaly namer
I am the game master resident here at
the same to his chest up
welcome and today we are going to be
playing a few blitz games online so yeah
so join us and I'm going to try to give
some comments and yeah just to try try
and to play some good games alright
let's do let's do it
three plus zero alright and I am white
that's not good efore another mystic
versus our nominee another's alright so
we have the ruie the Rui Lopez od6
alright I want to try to play a CT okay
this guy is a pretty good now the the
key here is to play move I don't know
I'm not sure about the small veg six
what is that though should I take the
knight or should I not the guy I'd like
to keep my two bishops let's go back
nicely simple development Bishop e7 I
would have to it did finish myself now
let's see if I can immediately put some
pressure here on black
I want this move e5 can i play five take
take night eggs yeah let's do it that's
different this King is still a scepter
we're gonna try to mess things up over
here after we take only five
now he's thinking Knights to h5 okay so
immediately I can see that this x-ray of
the other night over here questions what
shall we do
interesting
this guy's actually not so bad
that's so bad let's take a 96
about a 94
okay so if it castles and one think of
the six take knowledge 5 takes the Queen
I have an interminable 937 check so
hopefully it's not castle
wonderful castle
yes and he did castle
okay well you do get upon for that
should I give you the part I'll give you
a pond I'll do it this one
Faith's gladly follow they're just
differences so let's play g4 that's
vacated it's just that's why we are here
to create four five six
is his fighting he's a father but coming
to tokens to pieces down
fighting if indeed putting the rocks on
the seventh take a c7 we move and we
have a victory okay let's go do another
game as the bullet game I'm not sure
that's alright such a good put bullet
clear itself 75 35
okay other stuff I just want to castle
g4
of course so asymmetrical
so you can point up but
ninety days coming
this one whoa what is going on here what
is going on here
take my bishop bishop here in each for
now that's trouble
I smell some trouble
nothing good move
I just I'm just going to grab all the
parts we'll see how that works and I and
two plus one never play this one to
postpone bullets that's our native thing
to plus one bullets
somebody does not want to pay against me
two plus one is not not exactly a bullet
anyone that does play pretty good and we
got to a first girl out here really
interesting tasting stuff going on here
d4 you can't play like the quality
posing so in those things stuff is going
on let's just take here this way I'll
check that you're fine they can take on
b5 b6
[Music]
see what he got 31 I really like this
pony for thinking some things are going
to have it here definitely going to
happen
okay so what do I do now the questions
before
take me for
[Music]
simple okay so I'll lose the to Bishop
advantage but oh you went back let's
take the night here stay this night
let's take this day
what is that what is going on here okay
a lot they differ okay so so far so good
so far so good
that's the focus now
this
and blackheads I'm good game good game
it's kind of a reverse reverse the
girlfriend we have here two minutes all
right let's do one more bullet I think
both speak in 45 five six
okay okay he gets lots and lots of
[Music]
I got a fun
why not
I can get all my nuts
okay
[Music]
it's all of other people's here so I
love other people's guys it's things
change the Queen's broke over here okay
so that's story
doing something is vacant using fake
excuse me yeah that's that's that's play
interesting interesting chess as we said
that's why we're here
whoa that was not
it's just losses now it's just us
[Music]
she's lost
okay now it's just now he's nothing be
the square
[Music]
check with him okay toast I do BAM
alright let's see let's do it three
minute game now maybe maybe maybe gonna
be the last one just a casual game how
do we stop it
today c4 okay beat Lee who is about to
copy for me but isn't gentlemen we have
a copycat ooh wow what is going on here
really that is going to be interesting
to see how shall we punish a copycat
ninety-seven later it's not playing 97
Louisville Kappa killing that's that's
just development nothing too serious I
forgot that I'm not gonna go for a walk
have some some some thinking to do fish
5 supposed to be good supposed to be
good it is something here is just not
right
I feel at once
right
let's do this
oh then this time
that move Bishop Tito was just too
greedy bad
[Music]
let's go fish so just seven
but they more solid
it takes the refined father he won't
take the knight on f6 songs nights
really once night I wrote these sellers
come back it's my deal huh okay I can
have so many choices
we just take this mission there Lucas
Topanga by the way I believe it's true
how many I can think
define okay I should have taken this
much much easier in my life but the
changes before the hunt is destroyed
actually has nowhere to go except it's
fun let's see if it's not
it did go touch okay so now I want to I
want to come back to the sound oh no
really no no no that's no good
how do we check that this will be a nice
jacket
gonna be a nice gentleman oh maybe I
should do c7o d8 no leaders under
checkmate okay guys that's pretty much
for today
that was a blitz blitz many what we call
here so thank you so much for joining us
this was international master of Italian
aimer from the st. Louis chess club
[Music]